Từ nêu thêm của số nội dù sao?
Cực tiến cho thấy đâu có quý lánh đạo xù sát chính quyền tổ chức quyền liền
các người gặp với hợp chặt chá đồng bộ thiệu đó cũng tóc bầu cử
được tiến hành nghiêm tục nè nè đúng phóc lời rất dất dự quả?
Tìu đó, một lần nữa không khẳng đấy,
để cũng tóc bầu cử thành công yếu tố quói nghiêm quyền để sử lánh đạo chỉ thạo
thống nhất từ chúng hơn đến cơ giờ gắn với tình thành chủ đạo sáng tạo và chắc nhập cao của cải thống chi chỉ.
Bà học thứ hai là không tất nhiên sự
phải đều trận bị thật ki lớn thật dân chủ, thật đúng phóc lời và thật sự về lợi chủ.
Chất lận đại biểu quy định chất lợng mà đậu bộ khói và hỏi đồng nhiên dân các cấp
vì vậy trong tình không từ hiệp thương giới thiệu thậm chát công bố dành xác tiếp sức cử chi
đến tổ chức bỏ vếu và kìm vếu đều phải công khai quyết bại chặt chẽ khách qua.
Bộ cử thành công không chỉ là bầu cử xu lợp mà quan trọng hơn
lửa trọng được kính người thật sự của đức có tài màn lính của năng lực thành đạo của tình thành phục sự.
Nhưng rất bà, bà là phải lấy người rất là mục tâm của toàn bộ của chính bầu cử.
Bị lệ cử chi đi bầu cao nhất từ trước đây đây không phải chỉ nhờ tổ chức tốt
mà quan nhờ cử chi thấy được mình tôn trọng được thông tin đầy đồ được tạo được kẹp thuật lại nhất để thực hiện quên công rật.
Về tổ chức bỏ vếu sớm 2,5 mũi vầy khu vực đặc thồ mũi một đều phương trong thấy tình thành không đẹp bất kịt tự trí nào bị đứng ngoài trong những ngày hội dân chủ của đất nức.
Đây là bà học rất quan trọng về tính báo chồng và vẻ bảo đảm quyền bộ cử thực chất trong mọi người dân mọi vùng biển trong mọi điều kẹp.
Bà tư tư là công tất không tin tuyên trân về đi trước bộ bước và đồ mới mạnh mẽ cả về nội dụng là đường phương thức.
Trong bối khảnh trình thông số phát triển ngang, nếu thông tin chính thống không đến đủ ngang đủ gió đủ gần dân,
phí rất dế có khoảng trống thông tin, bí lấp đầy và những thông tin xanh thông tin thiếu sự kịp chứng.
Bộ bầu cử của quà cho thấy khi chúng ta kết thập tốt, tuyên chuyện trực tiếp ở cơ sở của nền tảng số,
lửa lửa sân kưứng dụng công nghệ của trình thông đá dạ thì hiệu quả ở đồng cân dẫn và tạo đồng thuật.
Bộ sau sẽ cao hơn rất nhiều. Bây giờ tương năm và cũng là bài học lớn nhất là thành công của một cộ bầu cử.
Chỉ thật sự trọng vẻ khi được trị ngoá thành kệ quả vào đồng của những kì mới.
Lá phiếu của kỳ chi không dừng lại ở ngày bầu cử.
Lá phi oi phải được kết nối, mọi chất lượng là pháp, mọi người lực giám sát, mọi người cũng có sách lúng đắn kìa thầy,
đặc biến nhiều cầu phát triển của đơn nước trong thời đợi mới, chính vì vậy, chách nghiệm của cố hội quả mwy sấu hội đồng như dân các cấp,
nhưng khi tháng nhìn không trong hài sấu, tháng nhìn cũng trong mai mốt của cộ tương vị đại biểu chúng cử là rất lớn.
Vậy nhé, chống của thẻ ngoá, nhìn tin của cử chi thành hành động, thành sản phẩm lập pháp, thành hiệu quả giám sát,
hổ tháng nhìn có cơ sách tiếp tượng để phụ cụ như rất phụ cụ phó chạm.
Đất lợp!